today we're gonna be talking about the
progressive framework the progressive
JavaScript framework view and the first
order of business is to just settle the
questions what exactly is or what are
JavaScript frameworks and why do we care
what problems do they solve based on the
crowd it looks like people probably have
a good handle on this but having been in
a recent conversation with a senior
developer and a junior developer I feel
like we should probably just dial back
and talk about why we have frameworks in
the first place so a few weeks ago I was
out with a colleague of mine who was
actually in the crowd tonight or this
morning rather and he was arguing that
we have frameworks to deliver value
value to our users and that's the stance
that I take on framework that's what
they serve for me they are a faster way
to get from A to B now our other
colleague he was arguing that we had
frameworks for the sake of making more
correct code which is also fair we want
to make correct code that's right
but not necessarily at the expense of
our users today I'd like to be talking
about why view is so simple and how it
can help us deliver value to our users
faster and quicker and iterate better
and give them the product that they
actually want whether we're working on
open source code or whether we're
working for you know dollars and cents
like some people the ultimate goal is
deliver value to our users view is a
very simple way of delivering the value
to our users so slide it over to some
code here and we're actually just going
to dive right in this is more or less
the canonical hello world of just pure
HTML everybody see that okay all right
perfect
you can zoom in and out as needed
there's not much to HTML as we should
all know at this point we can type in
hello world if I flip over to my browser
and that's hoping I could squeeze them
both in but that's probably not gonna
fly here so I'm just gonna slowly toggle
between them when I need to get back and
forth and I'll give you some fair
warning here so very first we got hello
world we can refresh this nothing to it
now we could go and we could edit some
other things like we might want to say
put in a button
do something it's a useful button and
save that and slowly flip back to our
browser and hit refresh and there's that
do something button this is basic 101
HTML of course this doesn't do anything
this is where our JavaScript comes into
play so if we flip back to the browser
it's not really obvious - especially non
developers folks who are maybe exploring
this space for the first time it's not
obvious how you would wire these things
up the pattern has changed over time
because flash forwarding backwards in
time when the web first was born what we
were actually dealing with were
documents and we're gonna see in the
very next code snippet that document
rear its head so let's take a look at
something slightly more dynamic I'm
gonna flip over to my little sidebar
here and open up a simple vanilla
JavaScript program so we're not in the
framework territory yet we've got a very
similar layout to below we've got our
full HTML document we've got a little
div here a division four labeled app
it's where we're gonna put our stuff and
then we finally have this mysterious
source code sitting here in the middle
and what we're doing in this source code
is we're saying hey let's let's grab
this element by its ID and assuming we
get something back and it's working
let's actually you know inject some text
into it and pop our hello world out and
again if we flip back to the browser
switch tabs here and refresh we can see
my little view here we've got that's the
same source code we were working on it's
running just as it was written and it
pops out our hello world nothing to it
the things we have to watch out for and
the reasons why we're going to start
looking at frameworks
are that we don't really want to be
working this way and it should become
more obvious to all of us if it isn't
already but we shouldn't be doing this
the very first thing here is I've put in
this extra if if we get an element back
let's inject hello world into it so out
of the box we already have to do some
error detection we already have to
look at our code and say hey is this
actually gonna work the way we were
going to work we have to do error
checking and we're starting to get into
logic even though all we're doing a sign
hello world and that's not ideal so
again going back to frameworks I like to
think of frameworks somewhat like a road
without a framework or without a road if
you wanted to get to A to B you've got
to walk through fields you've got to
walk through for us
maybe there's a fallen log in the forest
and you've got to crawl over it and then
you do it and you get to the next step
and maybe walking it a bit easier but
then there's another log and you're
crawling over it and over and over and
used to repeat all of that and it's not
great the framework or the road gets you
from A to B much much faster
there's no logs to traverse you don't
have to repeat yourself well see that
you do a little bit but ideally you
don't have to repeat yourself and you
get to where you're going so let's take
a look at what hello world in view might
actually look like and this is very very
simple much like the last example we
looked at it's actually slightly larger
in terms of code we've got an extra line
or two but as you'll start to see even
though sometimes our actual straight Dom
calls are a little bit quicker view
starts to give us this structure of this
road it's gonna get us from A to B view
is simple it removes some of that
complexity that's gonna get in our way
and slow us down and that complexity is
going to slow us and slow our abilities
to deliver the value to our users that
they need so in the view world we have
very similar layout we've got a division
it's also called app just like in the
last example except here we change up a
bit we bring in this this vue.js file
and it doesn't matter what framework you
you sooner or later you're gonna have to
bring in source code but the amazing
thing about view the simple thing about
view is that here in this just 16 lines
of HTML we're actually able to do a
full-fledged app there's no tooling
there's no build system there's nothing
it's it's actually very much like the
old days of say jQuery or prototype or
some of those libraries that some of you
might have worked with about 10 years
ago or possibly yesterday I
[Laughter]
and that's okay too I mean there's a lot
of different solutions out there a lot
of different problems that have to be
solved not every tool is the right tool
for every job but view is a great tool
for a lot of different jobs makes life
simple and that's one of the things that
I like about it so we bring in our view
Jas normally we might grab this from a
CDN or it might be built in our build
system typically we don't actually write
software this way but it's just a nice
way of illustrating how simple it is so
we pop in view I've loaded it locally
because I wasn't sure about network
access today and then we have another
little script down here that says hey
after views loaded let's make a new one
so we got that new view we're gonna bind
it to that app element and you can
already see my editors kind of
highlighting things for me it's a nice
piece of modern tooling it's nice to see
it working in HTML and JavaScript and
then we have this data property on this
object that we're constructing with you
and we actually seed it with a message
and it's no coincidence that this
message actually lines up with the stuff
and the mustache braces here or the
curly braces so if you actually rotate
them sideways
they look like mustaches I don't know if
anybody's ever noticed that dude
common slang and web development so
let's actually see this in action I'm
gonna flip back over to that browser
simple view oh there was a little extra
on there and we'll get there in a second
but you can see there's hello world
there's our script everything is loaded
as is there's no translation and
nothing's going on has very very simple
message gets put in and you see that you
gives us back just that division with
the hello world in there so what I'm
gonna do is flip back to the code and
just expand on this slightly so we've
got data we've got message what if we
wanted to add something else we could
say something like I'm not feeling very
creative this morning I'm sorry
Saturday's usually my day to sleep in
but I mean we just call this foo and
we'll add a property called foo and it's
gonna say something like good morning
Toronto let's actually explain that well
shout it out get the let out a little
bit today good morning Toronto feel like
a a little bit more awake now I come
back over here i refresh and there it is
playing this day right in our code
and I haven't had to do anything else
now flipping back to the code if we
looked at say the simple vanilla
JavaScript version again it would be
very very easy for us to do something
like just say come over here and then
say good morning Toronto and that will
work just as well I can flip I can write
that in there I can flip back to my
browser refresh it and we get the exact
same output or a similar output I've
made a typo in the name of the city but
aside from that more or less we're
working with what we would expect now
the downside is if we flip back to the
code the problem is now we've got two
pieces of text that we might want to
actually separate some of us are coming
from development backgrounds where we've
been trained to separate our concerns
and this approach here is just not
really gonna work now if we flip back to
the view approach change tabs it's much
clearer here that we have two separate
pieces of data for all we know as like
developers this could be coming from two
different API endpoints that we're
talking to it doesn't really matter what
or where it's coming from the point is
that we can actually separate it very
easily and as users we can sit here or
as developers we can sit here and read
this and say hey message foo I think I
know what's going on it's pretty simple
and it is and it's good so moving along
with our examples here the next thing
that makes view really simple and
powerful is it's change detection system
change detection is not unique to view
every framework has a method or a system
for it in some capacity or another views
is just like the rest of you quite
simple quite elegant and easy to use so
if we take a look at I'm gonna just open
vanilla JavaScript first this is a bit
more of a messy file there's a lot more
going on in this particular example and
I'm gonna flip to the browser and just
show you what it does what it's really
gonna do is it's gonna take one of these
edible items in this list and every two
seconds it's random we're gonna change
the one that's being displayed the very
trivial example we get that element just
like we did before we have a list of
things in real world this is obviously
not going to be done in an HTML file
from an API or something we set the
innerhtml like we did because this is
you know hacky vanilla JavaScript and we
have this set interval business going on
down here where it's basically saying
just randomly pick an item from this
list so let's see that in action one
more time two more tabs over there you
go I went a little bit too big on that
and you can see that it's it's actually
changing here and this is the script
we're running it doesn't really pretty
print nice in this browser but you can
see that that's the native code and
things are changing so this doesn't
really change detection I'm actually
just overriding the inside of an HTML
element it's actually not what we want
to do at all the reason I did that is
because if we were looking at this
vanilla JavaScript and if we wanted to
do some sort of change detection we're
actually gonna have to write a lot more
code more code than I really want to
walk through right now and more code
then will fit on a screen so let's look
at views answer to change detection and
we're kind of setting up a problem here
because this is pretty concise and the
view business think for this example
might look a bit longer
sometimes that's been the case no not
too much very similar we have our
message we have our edibles the main
differences we're bringing in that view
javascript again but the thing to notice
here is what we're doing differently
than the other example is in our
interval instead of wiping out
everything that was in that inner HTML
we're actually saying hey let's just
rewrite this message property on this
data object that we've broken out let's
rewrite the message property and see
what happens and because view is
relatively clever if we flip back over
to our browser and we look at the view
version of this pop down the script tags
you can see there's all the view stuff
pretty simple code it's doing the same
thing and in fact I've I guess in my dry
run today I left in this bold bit of
text so I'm gonna just remove that
really quickly
oh no I didn't maybe I didn't refresh oh
there it is good so well we'll get we'll
build up to that again in a second you
can see it's changing things here but
the power that I really want to talk
about is that and this is again true of
other frameworks it's just use a little
bit simpler is that if we flip back to
our code and we add in something at the
top like we'll make a strong element and
we'll say edible save it foot back to
the browser very quickly suddenly we
have this bold edible text but our foods
actually changing our edible item is
actually rotating and we're not
obliterating that edible so if we flip
back to the code again we've got edible
we've got message so we're able to start
writing a very declarative HTML again
similar to other frameworks it's just in
view it's very simple we're able to set
all of this up with no build tooling no
fancy like overlays on top of our HTML
or JavaScript or anything like that we
just have straight-up text and in 24
lines we've got a good change detection
example and we're not obliterating this
edible bit so just drive that home if I
flip back to the vanilla JavaScript and
we tried something like that and I put
in you know strong edible and we go back
to our browser see what's going on I got
to refresh it there we go it never even
shows up because right out of the box
our inner HTML code that we wrote just
obliterated that and what that leaves us
with is this problem of in vanilla HTML
we've got to organize all this code if
we wanted to write it we can we can go
ahead it's fine just like walking
through the forest or walking across
that field but we constantly have to
hurtle these fallen trees or you know
traverse rivers things that bridges were
built for things that roads were built
to solve and view solves these problems
so let's let's take it up to the next
example there's a tool that every modern
framework has that everybody's pretty
excited about
it's called components view does
components and the nice part about views
components is that
what frameworks popular single-page
application JavaScript frameworks have
been sort of a mainstay for I guess
eight years now seven years odd and in
that time there was a bit of a
divergence between frameworks and then
they sort of started to converge back on
this component pattern and what
components about us do is essentially
write our own custom HTML and this
becomes really really handy because we
can then start to define our views and
our applications up here in declarative
HTML so other people can read it
designers who might not want to work
with code can actually come in here and
just take a building blocks that have
been built for them and assemble really
interactive apps and then produce value
for their users again that's the whole
crux of this framework Lang we want to
deliver value to our users and quickly
so we can fix it because chances are
we're gonna give them something they
don't want the first time around just
the unfortunate reality of programming
everybody says they want X you give them
X and then they really want Y so the way
we combat that is with tools that let us
you know go from X to Y as quickly as
possible so there's component business
here we have made our own bold tag so
just like in the last example where we
went strong now we've just come up with
our own little bold tag again we're not
gonna do this in real life this is silly
but it's a great little example so
coming down here we got a slightly
different flow we're still bringing in
that that view code that's gonna help us
out in the background over here we're
saying hey view make a component and
register it globally in your application
we will call it our own bold just like
this so that lines up directly this our
own bold lines up exactly with the HTML
tag we've made and then we can put in a
template so we can put in this template
here and say hey this is just going to
be a strong tag just like in our
previous example the one little piece of
magic it's this slot business so view
provides a mechanism for projection and
they call it slots and you can have a
much more sophisticated layout than this
I'm sure somebody later in the day is
gonna get to something fancy in view
because there's a lot of deep dives
coming up a lot of great speakers but
this is the basic canonical example of
slots or transclusion or projection
whichever sort of vernacular you want to
use
grab this thing we want to put something
in the middle of our tags and so when we
use this this important text actually
gets stuffed in down here where the slot
is let's take a peek at that in action
flip back over to our browser just zoom
in a bit and refresh so there's our
important text it's bold
that's it not very much to that but the
concepts really important these
components we want to put into trees
it's everything we do here is a tree
with say the body being the root in this
case or the HTML being the root we can
expand body we can expand app we're
going down branches of trees and it's
really really nice for composition we're
gonna be building component trees with
you much like we're gonna be building
component trees with any other framework
just again with view we're able to set
all of this up in pure JavaScript and
demo a component without any tooling in
20 lines of code and have it all in one
self-contained file tried to keep all
the HTML in this just to really drive
home how simple view is but it gets
better where we can go with you next is
the second data example so this I think
we've already kind of danced around this
a little bit but in this example it's
essentially what we've done before and I
just highlight it the same example is
previously where we're switching between
these edibles except now we have the
bold in there it's our own custom bold
tag and view is correctly updating the
view without obliterating that edible
which is exactly what we want so
flipping back to the code not much to it
it's just really really nice it gives us
these abilities to compose increasingly
complicated things now if we were to do
this in native JavaScript we could
definitely do this it just it would be a
little bit more work we're gonna have to
hop around those logs and in the demo
that I set up for the native JavaScript
version I just cheated I mean it just
does the exact same thing and I think I
mean I think I cheated if I wanted to
cheat I would have done something like
put the strong in here like this
and slash strong and then our you know
concatenate them or come up with some
function or some other systems of doing
this I don't want to have to do that I
don't want to build the road I want to
drive the road to where I'm going so I
can deliver value to my users but
there's more the next stop are events
what good is an application if we can't
interact with it so in vanilla
JavaScript we can get at events like a
click for example pretty easily we can
say hey get us this element and we can
say hey maybe set the innerhtml
we're just setting in our HTML for this
example so we actually have something to
click on because we didn't put anything
in there there'd be nothing and then we
can actually bind to a click event and
cause some sort of side effect when
somebody clicks in this case we're just
gonna pop up a cheesy dialog box just
somewhat inspired by that earlier
conversation of talking about where the
junior dev was talking about program
correctness and it just came out of
happenstance that junior dev had never
lived through alert based debugging you
know we're really spoiled these days if
I flip over to the browser we've been
looking in this wonderful console here
this is a relatively new thing that in
the last 10 to 15 years has really
transformed the way we've been working
in the web space we didn't have this for
a long time what we used to have to do
was take our data and pop it in one of
these alerts so we could figure out
what's actually going on under the hood
now this is really no way to live but it
does demo that weekend it does demo that
we can at least you know display stuff
to the user and that's all well and good
but there's a lot of problems with this
it's not really necessarily obvious what
the problems are but right out of the
box we have to get a reference to an
element so we have to know where it is
we have to be able to find it as our app
grows that gets increasingly complicated
we also have to add an event listener to
it has our app grows and as we show
things and hide things this also gets
complicated because every time we add
one of these event listeners we actually
allocate a tiny piece of memory
somewhere in the system and that's not
really a big deal when we're doing it
once and we're not hiding the things but
over time if you're showing and hiding
things progressively it's very easy to
accidentally make a memory leak so
frameworks they give us a handle on how
to do this in a cleaner
so if I open up the view version as you
can immediately see like in some of the
other examples it's a little bit longer
however as we scale this lengths
actually turns into shortness so what
we've done in this case we've got our
app we've got our message we've used
this magical view syntax here to say hey
on : event so unclick let's call an
alert method and we've added this extra
property down here to our view object
that's called methods and we've given it
one called alert
that's just calling alert so a little
bit verbose we could do this in a few
different ways that are a lot shorter
but I wanted to just detach things and
illustrate probably a more correct way
of doing it and having us call methods
now some people who have worked in
vanilla JavaScript probably saying yeah
but you can do that in JavaScript and
you can like we could flip back to our
JavaScript we could say something like
click or is it no it's on clay sorry on
click equals alert foo we'd do something
like that which is great I mean we can
put that in line but then we have to
have access to whatever this alert is so
I'm just gonna flip to the browser
really quickly I think yep good I'm
still in the vanilla json' you can see
we've added this on click alert if I
click on there now I get the foo and
then I get the hello the problem with
this approach in vanilla JavaScript if
we flip back to the code it's not
inherently obvious but this alert method
that we've called it's a global that's
available everywhere in our browser if
we wanted to start using our custom
methods we would actually have to expose
them to the browser if we wanted to use
this mechanism it's a great mechanism
but the problem is we have to get data
to it somehow so it knows where to find
it whereas in the view system click over
there
all we really have to do here is say oh
v dot on click alert and alert does not
have to be global alerts actually
stuffed over here in this in this
methods collection and there are even
better ways in view of cleaning this up
especially when you get into the
component model I'm sure there'll be
demos up a little bit later so if you
solves a lot of problems with
and makes our life easier and just to
prove that it works we'll flip back to
the browser refresh and there you see I
can click on it it says hello so not
much to it but there's more we have to
do with apps we don't just display text
we don't just process clicks from users
we actually have to collect user input
and generally probably stuff it in a
database or send it back to a server do
something useful with it but it turns
out view is a full batteries included
framework and it actually includes
methods for handling forms and input and
output so our vanilla JavaScript example
what we've done is in this case I've set
up a more elaborate HTML blob we've got
our app just like before but now we have
this input and it has its own ID called
in it's got a placeholder and we've got
a slot for our outputs it's also labeled
out now in vanilla jeaious we would have
to say hey let's grab this input element
and you know it might not exist
I didn't bother doing error checking in
this case but it might not be there and
that will throw you for a loop and we
also have to grab the output and again
also might not be there but we didn't do
error handling so just to keep this as a
terse example however in the real world
we wouldn't really want to write vanilla
J s that's not checking for these things
and then finally we add our event
listener on change and whenever our box
changes we're gonna just update the
output so let's see what that actually
looks like so we flip over to the
browser blow that up a little bit and
we'll refresh this so edit me alright
let's see if we can spell Toronto
correctly this time and you'll notice
I've typed I'm still typing and
nothing's really changing yet but if I
hit enter it changes and that's just
because if we look in our source code
here we scroll down we're just listening
to this change event but we might want
to have something that's a little bit
more dynamic and it turns out there's a
lot of ways we could do that in vanilla
JavaScript it's just a lot more work
that we would actually have to do now in
the view example this is where things
really start to heat up and
really really started to enjoy view if
we look at the view code for this
finally we're in territory we're
actually in close to even range with
what we're doing in vanilla JavaScript
we have a relatively simple app division
not too different from the one we just
did in the vanilla HTML except the
difference is we were able to say hey
view just use this v-model binding that
you have built into your system bind to
the message property which again
messages here on line 5 here and also on
line 12 here so we've got that's all the
same message property that we're
referencing in three different spots and
here's the really fun part if I flip
back to the browser now and if I bring
up the view the view version and we
refresh to make sure we've got it all
says hello world let's just say Toronto
and you'll notice I spelled Toronto
again wrong but aside from typos you'll
notice that as I type everything is
updating in real time I can go back I
can go forwards and that is really
really handy we haven't if we look at
the source code here we haven't in our
actual JavaScript specified any of that
anywhere
there isn't source code saying hey
listen to a change meant there isn't
source code saying listen to unblurred
there isn't any of that stuff it's just
this few lines of new view here's a
message the rest is all in templates and
that is really really handy it means
somebody who doesn't know JavaScript can
come along come into a source code
editor and they could take some HTML and
all they have to know is that hey
there's something in the data call the
message and we want to bind to it that's
it and again other frameworks give you
this power but to do so in 17 lines of
JavaScript without tooling without
downloads without minification build
systems this is a wonderful property so
that in essence are the basics of why
people are loving view why it's a great
simple framework and why it could be a
solution to your problems so
what's next that is hopefully answering
what our JavaScript frameworks why we
have them and a little bit about how and
what makes you so simple the next thing
I'd like to talk about are upgrades so
everybody has seen a little bit of a
view probably already interested given
that you're out here on a Saturday
morning but how do you get view into
your app how can you leverage it today
how can you deliver this value to your
users and there's a number of different
tabs you can do some folks they're gonna
go for full-fledged upgrades they're
gonna take their whole existing app and
they're gonna say let's move this all to
view right now but let's let's remember
if you is a progressive JavaScript
framework we just we don't need to
introduce it all in one shot we flip
back to that code really quickly we can
see just how lightweight it is sorry
I'll just look on this window instead we
can see just how lightweight it is
there's really not much to it so it's
easy to start adding component by
component view to your system but I
don't want to pretend like upgrades are
easy because upgrades are never easy
every application is different there
aren't really clear-cut paths to what
the upgrade story looks like for anybody
and that is always a challenge every app
needs to be upgraded they need to stay
in shape upgrades as I've gotten a
second point here they're always painful
I mean even code that's architected
really cleanly and really well to be
resilient to upgrades can be painful to
upgrade and I experienced that over the
course of the week well I upgraded a
package that I'm gonna demo in a few
minutes
and I ran into sort of all the classic
problems we run into with modern
JavaScript tooling when I did it the
first bit out of the gate is routing is
challenging you've got a router that's
probably built into your framework that
you're using and it's probably loading
components up from your framework maybe
you don't have that if you're using
something a little bit more traditional
like say your jquery's and your lighter
pages then you can start using view in
really easily but if you're doing single
page application development just sort
of my bias I tend to I've been doing a
lot of single page application
development over the last decade upgrade
stay get challenging the problem with
these upgrades and the reason they're so
challenging is that it's very easy when
we're developing take business logic
and slip it inside of the framework code
inside of our view layer and as
developers we want to make sure that we
are always separating these concerns so
we can keep our lives simple so
generally speaking the cleaner the
architecture the easier the upgrade but
again your mileage is going to vary
depending and I thought that I had an
app that had a relatively clean
architecture for upgrading and it it did
in a lot of respects but it it still had
its challenges and part of that was
because it hadn't been maintained part
of that was because of the dependencies
it's failed part of that was because the
JavaScript ecosystem moves very quickly
and the packages again dependencies it's
tailed but that meant to build system
its tailed and even getting a build out
it took a while to get that out there
the first thing though that I like to
see in any sort of upgrade path is a
separation a clean separation of that
business logic because we all have
business logic in our apps if we didn't
we wouldn't really have apps we'd
actually just have demos or showpieces
or some sort of really nothing the
business logic is the thing that's
delivering the value to your users and
again depending on the app of your
choice there's many ways to
progressively include you so the app
that I decided to upgrade for this
particular use case it happened to be
it's a game so it's not business II but
it's a game that's built in the Dom it's
a block dropping game so if you think
like dr. Mario or Tetris that kind of
thing I built this about a year and half
ago on an airplane just one of those
developer things really oh it's so
simple and then you know it wasn't I
ended up spending a lot of my holiday
trying to get it to go but that's what I
like to do in my free time so you know
to each their own so let's take a look
at what we've got here if I flip over
all right so
so you can tell I obviously work at a UI
company because this is the cleanest UI
ever but that's not really the point the
point of this program was to see what I
could develop on an airplane pretty
quickly and again it turned into some
holiday programming but that's it I've
got three buttons here industrial
developer in view and they're all three
different frameworks it wrote this
application with the business logic very
much decoupled from the rest of the
program so much so that you can actually
switch between frameworks in real time
all right I'm going to refresh I'm gonna
click welcome and I'll just hop right
into the view version so there you can
see we have a simple block dropping game
and it's all done in the DOM and I can
actually flip between frameworks here so
if I come back over to this view here
where we can see our elements we can see
things like I flipped it say the
developer framework of choice you see
that display has gone to flex my view is
display:none and my industrial framework
display is none I can flip over to the
industrial back again and we can see hey
look there's that tree that I was
talking about earlier where everything
is sort of coming down and you can see
that these are all crazy amounts of text
coming down and again this isn't really
a business program
it's obviously a toy game but nope yeah
when I have developer tools open oh I
can actually do the the rotation this
kind of works but this is this is set up
for I think sort of dr. Mario rules
where you match enough colors and then
eventually the lines will disappear but
the point is more that as we flip around
in between frameworks it doesn't really
matter what we're using as our view
where since the business logic separated
everything just sort of works TM now of
course this was not the case and yes
great at all there were a lot of
challenges they weren't related to view
they again were more related to the
build system it's failed it took me a
good hour just to get things building
properly but again that's kind of a
problem we have with modern JavaScript
frameworks we've we've looked at the
apps we've built over the last decade
and built out all of this tooling and
then slowly but surely the tooling is
starting to get in the way of us
delivering that value
you are users and that's one of the
things I like about view is that the
tooling overhead is very minimal
so that's that's sort of a tale of what
it was like to upgrade it wasn't too bad
but even though I had architected for
success it was still I found flaws in my
architecture there were things was like
whoa this is repeated I violated that do
not repeat yourself business and it was
really really unfortunate but at the
same time crafting view on top was
pretty painless there was less code than
with the other frameworks and I got it
done pretty quickly so let's clear that
out so I'm not displaying that and
before we segue into the last bit like
to just take a second to talk about
Toronto view Jas meetups
so the company I work for wrangle
thought IO we've been hosting view Jas
meetups and we've got one coming up on
March 15th and somehow we've actually
managed to get Evan you the creator
review he's coming down so if you're all
interested in view you should definitely
try and come to the Meetup there's some
more details on the next slide here it's
a 7:30 to 8:00 p.m.
revenue is coming and I think the
tickets are going fast I took this
screenshot last night but even then you
could see there were a hundred and
fifteen people who had already
registered and I think the cap is
somewhere around 150 but don't quote me
on that go to the meetup site see if you
can still get in Evan you is coming and
it's gonna be great person to ask
questions too and with that out of the
way we're gonna wrap up with the case
for view so I'd love to use view on my
next industrial project full disclosure
I haven't actually used it on a consumer
facing project just side projects but I
fell in love with it because it reminded
me of why I got into web programming in
the first place I can look at a browser
I can get code I can make that code run
on anybody's device everybody here has
at least probably two or three devices
on their person that can render and run
software written on the web browser and
view makes that simple and that's one of
the things I like about it so the first
case I have for view is onboarding
onboarding is always a challenge whether
we're talking about folks who are moving
from the design space into programming
whether we're looking at like grizzled
programmers who've been working on
dotnet or
backends and things like that all sorts
of folks are moving to the web I can say
that from experience the last two and a
half years I've probably been inside
about 30 different companies talking to
people about how they can move their
developers over to JavaScript or
typescript in some cases and onboarding
is always a challenge even professional
developers with a decade of experience
they use their Java or they're done out
of their PHP and they say hey this looks
great
I can do JavaScript it looks exactly
like what I do and then they come and
they do their JavaScript and then they
realize that javascript is a really
weird language and then they have a bad
time and they do not go to space today
so the other thing about view that makes
it really awesome is that you only
really need four things to get started
you need a little bit of knowledge about
HTML some may be basic to intermediate
as we all know HTML anybody can figure
it out it's just a markup language
you're tagging things making them strong
but it can get really complicated so
let's not trivialize it people would
also need a basic to intermediate
knowledge of CSS we don't want to make
apps that look like the apps that I make
so maybe maybe I need to do some
upgrading on my skill set and to you see
you're going to need at least a basic to
intermediate knowledge of JavaScript
it's really really easy to get started
but again JavaScript as we all know it's
a little bit of a strange language and
there's lots of quirks and finally the
last thing you really need to be
successful and start with you is a good
text editor and a browser so you saw
today you can edit in straight HTML
refresh in the browser and it's really
easy and the great thing is the view
Doc's they really spell that out for you
when I read them the first time I was
like oh yeah I'm a developer I'm gonna
you know do my NTM installs and all this
stuff and then the docs for like no just
include a script tag what its 2017 I'm
not and anyway I sucked it up I did it
their way and I was so happy I I
couldn't even believe how simple it was
the thing about other frameworks not to
knock them but they do require all the
things a view requires and sometimes
more than an intermediate knowledge of
j/s but you also need the know package
management basics which for a lot of us
might be you know second nature however
for a lot of folks coming from other
environments you can spend half a day
just getting NPM working you might need
some CLI basics
which is like command line or
scaffolding because a lot of these
frameworks are coming with their own
command lines and view does and then
there might be some other information
that you need to know too
the other great part about view is it's
flexible and it has a large batteries
included official ecosystem it's got a
strong core it has routing it has state
management which Hassan is going to be
talking about a little later today
it's got template compilation so you can
optimize the app for distribution and
it's got this SSR business which is just
server-side rendering knocking out your
app on the server-side so you get better
SEO and quicker page loads that all
comes basically out of the box with view
and it's all officially supported so you
don't have to go find some library that
you never heard of but again it's
flexible so you can also just mix and
match your solutions in fact their
initial routing guide is just to roll
your own router with html5 and it's
perfect for a lot of needs and with all
that said I'd like to thank you all for
again for coming out on a Saturday
morning to talk about view I think it's
a great simple framework and I think we
should all be considering it for our
next projects all right thanks a lot
[Applause]